Okay, good morning everyone welcome to this session. I think it is the second part of
today's lecture and today we are going to discuss about data and mathematical structure.
I am Udhananda Banerjee from Mathematics Department IIT Kharagpur and by training and profession
I am a statistician. So my job here is to connect the data structure
to connect the data structure and the mathematical structure and the computer based data structure
that will be done in a subsequent way by other professors. So today we are going to address
or introduce some mathematical formulation and as well as statistical formulation of
the data which is the core of our analysis. So we are going to discuss about some data
driven problem I think I need to increase the font little bit.
So here are the examples of data driven problem that often we address it is and in a realm
of AI and ML it is automated data entry detecting spam product recommendation medical diagnosis
correcting and preventive measures in maintenance or manufacturing process speech detection image
or video recognition as a part of computer vision natural language processing you can
see the new application in chat GPT or deep seek whatever you say then video and online
games so and many more definitely. So these are the typical problem that we address nowadays
and these problems are become much more prominent because of the advancement of computer technology
in last few years. So storing and retrieving data has become much more easier compared
to the days maybe around 30 to 40 years ago. So the problem and the solution that we usually
get in our textbooks so called textbooks which are taught in after 10 plus 2 levels they may
not always have incorporated this type of problem. So these type of problems are new
because of the advancement of the technology the problems and the associated solutions
and the machinery for addressing those problems that you see in the textbook that are little
bit older compared to this new type of problems but the idea that we develop from those textbook
knowledges are always implementable to this new realm of problems.
So here are the connections schematic diagram that I have I can share with you that it all
this problem that we have just seen here that can be categorized into 3 or 4 roughly like
it is a clustering problem classification problem and regression or prediction or forecasting
type of problem. As a consequence we can divide the work in 3 large chunk of groups.
So how will the machine decide that is the first problem and that is solved by statistical
analysis of statistical inference or in which space the analysis has to be done for a correct
method that is solved by mathematics that is the mathematical structure and how will
the machine function between these two statistical and mathematical problem where physically
the data are stored in hard drive or some cloud or somewhere else it is flowing.
So that part is definitely taken care by the computer science. So in statistical aspect
of this data analysis we have few broader aspect one is estimation which eventually
known as learning how the machine learns we machine does not learn we have to tell the
machine how to learn and that part is nothing but estimation problem.
The testing of hypothesis problem which is eventually a decision making problem whether
you will go by one rule or by the other so that is a testing of hypothesis problem.
Interval estimation problem is broadly associated for the prediction problem or at the same
time point estimation problem where instead of one particular value we are looking for
a band or an interval which will be considerably good for application and then comes the model
selection which is the most challenging part. We need to remember that model selection is
done based on a suitably chosen set of assumptions the no model is the correct model but some
model works for a given data set and we prefer to use that one the challenge is to identify
that one. And now all these problems can be dealt in different setup either parametric
setup where the distributional assumptions are there, parameter space is defined and
then we have to search in that space. On the other hand there are non parametric setup
where the assumptions are less but at the same flexibility is more at the same time
accuracy often sometime less if the assumption is wrong.
Another paradigm is the Bayesian paradigm where we have little bit more assumption over the
parameters again it increases the flexibility as the assumptions are more the flexibility
becomes more because we have distributional pattern associated to the parameters.
Now notice that we can do all the statistical analysis on a structured space and that structured
space is provided by mathematical theories. For that there are many subjects in mathematics
the most applicable subject in this context is linear algebra which deals with high dimensional
data, how to move from one high dimensional space to another high dimensional space and
how to retrieve back information from there, how to summarize the data all these stories
are covered in linear algebra. Little bit more sophisticated and abstract space beyond
linear algebra is the functional analysis and even more structured and different geometric
space is differential geometry which is a more generalized version that you remember
is from the coordinate geometry its generalized version is differential geometry and topology.
So this differential geometry and topology these type of structures usually used for
shape analysis image analysis. Nowadays topological data analysis is very much popular for statistical
analysis also then graph theory which is a core of network analysis and finally at the
top of everything is the optimization problem because whenever we are trying to solve any
problem we are trying to optimize a cost function which may be in terms of minimization or maximization
over a restricted space. So all this structured space make possible to do statistics on it
and now you can see that whatever I have told in between these two columns they are pen
and paper job. So how to implement these two things together for the data that makes the
connection with the computer science. So it requires data storage, data retrieval, memory
estimation, signal transmission, data visualization, automated service and automated learning.
So whatever we are saying in these two columns that think if I have to do via a computer
I need to feed all the necessary structure in computer such that at the right point of
time computer can take the correct decision and that is what is eventually the machine
learning problem and the search we do in a mathematical space is not same as the search
we do in a computer space. So the knowledge of computer science is equally important and
useful for implementing this statistical idea and the mathematical idea.
So we are here whatever the part I will cover here is mostly this linear algebra and some
aspect of this statistics part as mostly we will deal with parametric inference. So this
is the topic I will cover in today to next week and the next to next week. I hope this
is the right time to move on to understand all this structure. So whatever thing we will
discuss here in terms of mathematics or statistics you might have learned earlier or you might
not have learned earlier. If it appears to you little bit hazy don't worry too much.
In subsequent application when it will be implemented through this computer science
aspect of it it will be much more clear because I am not using the coding part in my lecture
so I will not go through coding but visualization aspect and example of all those topics I will
try to cover. So now we are going to ask few questions which is very common to all of us.
So here you see that we have these questions very often in our mind but we do not discuss
too much about all this stuff. We take it for granted that when do we consider the rating
of a product in Amazon may be valid or useful. So any website you consider either Blinkit
or Amazon or Flipkart or Mointra or whatever. So there are product, there are rating of
the product and what do you think that the rating is correct or it is useful for you.
People always have a hunch that the rating that is provided there it might have a certain
amount of bias because some got up rating might be there or in other words also I will say
being a statistician that it has an underreporting problem because whoever is purchasing a product
that person whether the product is good or bad that person may not give the rating. Some
of the people may give the rating and same thing happens also when we study in biopharmaceutical
statistics which is a big industry I mean one of the top largest industry the pharmaceutical
industry where in phase 4 after launching the product in market when people take medicine
they have more than one medicine most of the cases they take more than one medicine together
and because of that the person might suffer from some adversary drug reaction which is
often usually we call the side effect of the drug or the medicine.
So we do not know which medicine directly causing that side effect or which combination
of the medicine is causing that side effect but it is also true that everybody who are
getting the side effect are not reporting the side effect. So whether the person is
getting a good feedback out of the treatment or getting the ADR they all are not reporting
the ADR or the good outcome of it. So these type of problem is suffering huge from underreporting
problem which is often ignored in the analysis. Why do we represent cat or net this type of
big exam in our country rank of a candidate in percentile? That means often it is given
the rank of the person and as well as the percentile of score of that person very easily
you can understand that suppose a subject which is appeared by say 500 people and one
person is getting rank 50 there how good that person out of 500 but at the same time may
be some subject which is not taken by many people 500 candidate is appearing for net
in a particular subject or may be some subject like mathematics or statistics.
Statistics is taken very less but say for example mathematics the 50 rank out of say 50000 candidate
across the country. So the potential of the candidate who is having rank 50 out of 50000
student is much more compared to the rank of rank 50 out of 500 student of any other
subject although it is the direct comparison is not so easy but apparently you can decide
in that way the base of the comparison is how many people. Even that is the thing is
always asked in any recommendation when being faculty member when we need to recommend of
our students to in the university where they were looking for PhD program or MS program
they often asked that based on how many students are you giving this rating.
So next question is how the chat form works at your smart phone? So you can see that in
your smart phone whenever whatever you type after that a certain prompt is coming and
if your phone is old that means you are using that phone for little bit long time almost
very often it is giving you the right prompt that you are willing to type but if your phone
is new you might not get that prompt or if you are willing to you are typing a text in
the phone of your may be say some of your household member you might not get the same
prompt or with some of your friend who is speaking in a different language specifically
may be your say Hindi speaking person and your friend is Karnar speaking person or Tamil
speaking person and often we talk in chat we write in our mother tongue but in English
Roman font but so whatever outcome you will get from your phone that might not be same
if you write the same word in your friend's phone. So how these type of structure are
often built and another big industry is this electronic health record it is now often also
known as the omic data. So this tracking of data like smart watch or any other devices
which can be attached with the body and many records physical biomarker records can be
captured so this development has unfolded many interesting aspect of data analysis where
we understand the structure of the data or the associated data associated to a particular
disease very well and the decision making scheme where earlier the people were taking
decision only based on certain feedback of the patients or by the feedback of by definitely
by the understanding of the physician whoever is checking or the doctor whoever is checking.
So what it has made it has made the measurement more finer or granular this development and
as a consequence we our job is now to understand the subtle changes which can be an indicator
of the existence of a certain type of physical illness which might be not so prominent in
the usual observation or the measurements.
And then why do we often get calls SMS mail from pre-approved loan or credit card which
you have not applied at all I think all of us is having this advantage or disadvantage
depending on our time and mood so when you do not need anything they will be calling
and saying that we have a pre-approved loan for you, pre-approved credit card for you
although you have not applied for so definitely whatever data you are willingly or unwillingly
generating through your bank that data is no longer in inside in your bank it is going
somewhere else and those people are analyzing your data and your transactions and you calling
you back for the same thing repeatedly.
So these are the topics which sometimes debatable sometimes controversial but these are genuine
issues which are practical at the same time deeply involved in our life and all these
things are happening only because of the computer enhanced data analysis using certain tools
that whether it is accurate or inaccurate that is a separate issue but certain outcome
definitely it is going to be producing which is having a great impact in our life.
It is our job to make the use of it in a proper stream or streamline way such that we can
get the best benefit out of it.
So let us move on well when we talk about the data these are few simple questions that
we should understand that why do we collect data or sample we collect data or sample to
understand the feature of the entire population either the entire population or some feature
of our interest from the entire population.
So what do we want to know about the variables?
So they are inherent structure first notice this thing this is not a situation where we
have certain mathematical equations or law or certain law of physics that we have come
across in from the very beginning of our study.
So here nobody is going to tell us the law only we have data so data is the manifestation
of the law and we have to extract out the law from that data and make use of it so that
is what we are going to do or we are interested to do.
So ultimately how we can represent all the characteristics or the features of the data
and the way we can the best way we can do it is by its joint probability distribution.
So gradually we will unfold what it exactly means by the joint probability distribution
maybe today we will talk about little bit probability distribution and the next lecture
we will talk about joint probability distribution but this is the thing which can capture all
the features together and that can be captured very smartly such that we can make use of
this data in future for most of the related problems.
So let us move on in this direction before going to that we have few structure of the
data that we often come across first type of data which is known as the categorical
data which is either nominal or ordinal.
So nominal data has name only without ordering.
So say for example in a person of different ethnicity people often do categorization like
say Asian, Australian, Indian or India, Pakistan, Bangladesh, Sri Lanka, the subcontinent together
then the Middle East, then the East European, West European, then that is other side in
the South American people or the Native American people and the other Americans who have or
the French people who are staying there in America and Canada like that or maybe depending
on the hair color like black, brown, gray, blondes, so on and so forth.
So you try to see that all are certain names only and we cannot order them based on any
parameter.
So this is one structure which is called nominal data.
Model data is little bit different, it has the name and the ordering but the magnitude
of the ordering is not, sorry I think, is everything okay?
So the magnitude of the ordering is not present.
So let me make it a little bit clear, suppose I have not reached up to that much.
Thank you.
So the ordering here say for example a patient comes with a severe arthritis problem or maybe
some arthritis problem and the pain level of that person may be mild pain, moderate
pain, severe pain and that we get from the patient feedback and the treatment should
be started based on the feedback of the patient.
We do not have any magnitude associated to it, how much is severe pain, how much is moderate
pain, how much is mild pain, only it is the word of the patient.
And the same amount of damage on the body of a person who is little bit more aged, the
same amount of damage may cause severe pain to an older person but a moderate pain to
an younger person.
So if you go by the magnitude of the measurement of the damage, that thing might be same but
the amount of pain is different for different age group of the people.
So here you try to understand, we do not have any number associated to mild pain, moderate
pain or severe pain.
You may ask that give a score out of it to the person but again that is also a vague
number, whatever the person will tell you, you have to go by it.
So in that way whatever ordering is done and the data generated that is known as the ordinal
data or if you go by say like, dislike, so and so.
So like is more superior in some sense compared to ok, then ok is superior in the sense compared
to dislike but you do not have any number out of it.
You may ask for a number to be given but again that is a vague number which people can assign.
But the end of the day the analysis should be free from all these numbers that is what
I meant to say.
The next type of data that we are going to look as the countable data which is very easy
for us to deal with and the values are either the integer or some function of the integers.
So it can have positive integer value, negative integer value, zero associated with it.
The number of spam mail you are getting each and every day for every hour, how many messages
are entering in your phone, if you upload a video in YouTube, how many likes and dislikes
you get, how many comments you get.
So all these are very nice examples of the countable data.
Now uncountable data is often represented over an interval.
So interval means suppose you have uploaded a video in your Instagram or YouTube then
after how much time the first viewer has appeared or the second viewer has appeared or after
how much time the first like you have got or how much time how first dislike has appeared.
So this time interval whatever you are seeing this is a number which is taking value between
zero to infinity.
So all these are these numbers you consider as an uncountable observation.
And often all the observations comes most of the cases with certain units.
Here are few examples with the diagrams that I have here.
For categorical data you have nominal like pen, pencil, eraser.
It has also nice market basket analysis people are doing for very long days that if you in
a say crossword or any other bookstore if you keep these type of things together people
have a tendency to grab one with the other even though they do not need it.
There is another categorical example like cow dog cat which have only name but no ordering
sense.
On the other hand excellent good bad it has name and a sense of ordering fantastic okay
do not like that they also have a sense of ordering but no magnitude.
Here is a color grid which in the left panel whatever you are observing here it has a continuous
grid which is moving gradually and depending on the magnitude the color is changing.
So this transition is a smooth transition which is representing a continuous variable.
On the other hand here you have only five category of colors and that category of colors
is representing five different segments of the data.
So this is the discretization of this continuous variable.
And let me tell you with discretization we often lose the information some information
but sometimes storing the data and analyzing the data might be easier but as an information
perspective definitely this continuous curve or continuous data will be much more efficient.
And all these data whatever we are observing they are considered to be a an outcome of
a mathematical function which is typically known as random variable.
So this is typically known as random variable and this random variable is a function which
is a function from a particular set of subsets to real number or a collection of real number.
So here depending on the intensity you have the color.
So the color is the final outcome but the intensity is the value so that thing we can
consider as a random variable.
And we often denote that random variable with a capital letter it need not be x it could
be something else also.
So this random variable is a statistical or mathematical object that we will be dealing
with.
So let me just give you another example of random variable and its representation.
So we consider a population say for example the Indian population.
So this is Indian population and we choose one individual from the entire population.
So this for this individual I can assign many variables associated to it.
So let us call x1 omega which is the weight of that person.
So definitely x1 omega belongs to say certain number technically it is not 0 so technically
may be say 5 to infinity.
If it is adult definitely but if it child or maybe I can use little bit less number.
So let us for sake of example make it from 0 to infinity.
On the other hand x2 omega it is the monthly income so that is x2 omega which is again
that can be lying between 0 to infinity everybody might not be earning but it can have positive
and negative number.
So x3 omega say number of brothers or sisters in short siblings so that is x3 omega.
So x3 omega can be either 0, 1, 2, so on and so forth.
So in this way you can associate numbers to this individual omega and this numbers are
ultimately the outcome of the function x1, x2, x3.
Here you can see this is a real number, this is a real number and this is an integer.
So all possible outcomes are in general here real number it can be categories also.
So x4 omega is here color so x4 omega it can be from the set white, black, brown, grey
so on and so forth.
So this is the category outcome.
So these are nothing but random variables you can discuss about only one random variable
or you can discuss about x1 omega, x2 omega, x3 omega, x4 omega all random variables together.
So this is often known as a random vector, individually it is random variable together
all of them is a random vector often we need to discuss all of them.
So another example might be the investment of different amount of money in different
stocks.
So the amount of return from each of the stock could be different numbers and they can be
studied together.
So all those examples we will come across I hope this is a as an explanation this is
an easy example to understand what is a random variable.
So now here are few diagrammatic representation of the motor train card data.
This is a very old data and the sample size is also not big intentionally I have not chosen
a big sample size because it will be easy to visualize.
This dataset is freely available in software R so I have used I hope there is another dataset
of similar type with 400 observations now it is available but this is a old data very
very old data long back.
So here we will just try to understand and visualize all the necessary thing out of the
data.
So here most important outcome just the most important outcome of this dataset is the my
per gallon information that what is the mileage of the different type of car.
So here how we can summarize the data that is the first and foremost challenge.
So to summarize the data what we do we can take many measurement few measurement are
taken to capture the center part of the data few measurements are taken to capture the
spread of the data and that is typically when we talk about only one random variable but
if we have more than one random variable then definitely the variation of one variable based
on the other is also an important aspect.
So first of all we consider the mean.
So mean is the average value of all the individual elements of the dataset.
Now notice the thing that if we go for mean the mathematical formula of mean is say 1
upon n sum over xi when i equal to 1 to n so this is the often known as the sample mean
and notice that if any of the value of this information is too big or too large say for
example all the data are lying between 0 to 1.
So 0.17, 0.49 something like that all are lying between 0 to 1 but in some observation
the decimal value is not present by mistake or typing error.
Then the fluctuation will be happening to this data is too much.
So suppose some number is 0.2 or say 32397 and if we remove that decimal value then it
becomes 2397 and with that number if a system is computing the mean the mean will have a
very high amount of bias.
So often that measurement of the center part of the data might not be a good one.
So mean typically what is the remark here that mean can be affected by extreme values
a lot. So to overcome that problem we introduce another notion which is the median of the
data.
Median of the data is known as the or conceptually it is the middle most data.
So if you have the observation first you sort the observation. So this is the minimum
X order 1, X order 2, X order 3. So within parenthesis this number means this is the
lowest one then the second lowest and then the third lowest so on and so forth going
on and X order n which is the maximum observation.
Now if you have these numbers you just try to track back whatever is the middle most
1. So if n equal to 2k plus 1 odd number of observation then there will be X order k plus
1 that is the middle most value. If n is 2k then any value between kth order value and
k plus 1th order value anything in between them could be considered as a median their
average also can be considered as a median. Now or any proportionate linear combination
so say 3.3 into this plus 0.3 into this plus 0.7 into this that will also be a median it
did not be the average. Mode is the value that appears most frequently in the dataset.
So just going to before going to mode so here you notice the thing that median is not so
affected by the extreme value. So even this much can be highly affected median is not
going to be changed or this much is going to be highly affected with negative sign or
so on and so forth the median is not going to be changed at all.
So mode is the middle most value of sorry mode is the mostly viewed data that means the high
data with high frequency. Data with maximum frequency that means whenever a dataset is
observed we often take the count of the data and we calculate how many observations that
data has of each of the individual and that value for which the frequency is maximum this
base value is known as the mode. Now you may ask this question if the data is continuous
type of variable where each observation is coming only once then what will be the mode
then often we will represent the data in the form of histogram in the form of histogram
and the pillar for which the maximum frequency we observe the middle most value of that pillar
you can consider as the mode from the data and from theoretical distribution what it
will be that I will tell you later on after introducing the theoretical distribution.
Now we are going to another measurement which is known as the dispersion. So this mean median
mode they are the measure of the central tendency and the dispersion measurement is capturing
the spread of the data. The first one is very obvious the range that is maximum observation
minus the minimum observation. So that is the range of the data often we call it R okay.
Then the most interesting part comes which is known as the variance okay. So variance
of the data let us try to introduce in the form so let me just check once again. So variance
of the data how can we interpret this one. So let me just go in this way. So suppose
if I have observation say 1.23.97.8 9.7 something like that and I want to summarize this data
by only one number okay and let us call this is x1, this is x2, this is x3, this is x4
and so on and so forth you can have n number of observations.
You want to summarize all the data with only one value okay. So let us call that value
is replace all of them by a particular number which is A okay. So every time I am replacing
1.2 by A I am committing some error, I am replacing 3.9 by A I am committing some error
and so on and so forth. So say you can have a very nice example that if you ask a student
that how much is your score at 10 plus 2 level, the person will give you a certain number
and you ask that why you are giving me this number, you tell it is the mean of all the
values in terms of percentage. Now if you ask the question that why are you talking
about the mean most of the cases we do not have a proper answer for that. So what we
are doing there is eventually we are giving one number instead of all the scores of the
individual subjects.
Now how much amount of mistake I am committing, if I consider the error in terms of the square
error, square error, so let us call s, the square error is xi minus A sum over i running
from 1 to say here it is 4 or in general it is n. So every time I am replacing the true
value by A I am committing this much of error and this is the total error. So if I want
to minimize the total error, minimize the square error with respect to A and the value
which will be minimizing the square error, A hat which is nothing but 1 upon 4 sum over
xi i running from 1. So this is another interpretation of mean that how much if I minimize the square
error loss, the best representative of the data is the sample mean.
Now after minimizing the square error, so the minimized average square error is 1 upon
n sum over xi minus x bar whole square i equal to n. So minimized average square error is
nothing but sample value. Now I am asking you to do this another, so this has another
interpretation that it is measuring the distance of individual data from its mean or the scatterness
of the data around me. It has another interpretation which is trivial to observe that this quantity
xi minus x bar whole square i running from 1 to n is same as 1 upon 2 n square double
summation ij xi minus xj whole square. So n in general here n equal to 4 in this case
i equal to 1 to n j equal to 1 to n. So these two things are same, the interpretation of
the right hand side is it measures the scatterness of the data among each other. So xi and xj
they are any pair of data points, pair means if you choose i and j, if i equal to j that
is trivial is 0. But if you choose any ij combination this right hand side expression is saying the
scatterness among itself and here it is measuring scatterness around the mean. Both of them
gives the notion of the variance. Now another connection I can also say that instead of
the square error if we use absolute error sum over xi minus, so this is one part xi minus
b i running from 1 to n 1 upon n. So let us call a it is a function of b. If I minimize
the absolute error, so b is so chosen that it minimizes the absolute error then the choice
of b is the median of the data.
So square error is minimized with respect to mean, absolute error is minimized with
respect to median. So this is a very fundamental aspect and that we can all consider and the
square root of variance is known as the standard deviation. So this is often known as SD. Interquartial
distance I will show you with the diagram later.
So here is the data set with mile per gallon for 32 car observation. Here you can see the
minimum first square error will come later on, median, mean, maximum all these things
are available. Variance of the data is here, variance of the data is here, rest of the
thing we will talk in a while. Range we have considered, mean absolute deviation about median
that is here. So now based on this if we want to write all of them summarized mathematically
then the expression of mean is given, median given, the mode we know. This portion we can
capture through either by the sample variance or through standard deviation. Mean absolute
deviation we can capture as 1 upon n sum over x i minus m where m is the median. Range we
know, interquartial distance that we will discuss, skewness cartosis we will come later
on. But if we have all those information do we know everything about the data? The answer
is no. This is a descriptive summary of the data. Still we do not know the entire feature
of the data. So here you can see that how the mean, median and mode are playing within
the data. If the longer tail is on the larger value of the data then it is known as positively
skewed. If the longer tail is on the lower side of the data it is known as the negatively
skewed and if both of them have the same weightage tail then it is known as the symmetric distribution.
As for positively skewed distribution mean is larger than median, median is larger than
mode. On the contrary for negatively skewed distribution mean is lesser than median, median
is lesser than the mode. For symmetric distribution mean median mode are same and this is true
for typically continuous value distribution. Now cartosis is another measure which is capturing
the peakedness of the data which is known as the cartosis. The standard normal distribution
so normal distribution which means 0 variance 1 that is considered to be the standard. If
the peakedness is more then it is known as the positive cartosis or platycardic. If the
peakedness is less then it is known as negative cartosis or sorry this is leftycardic and
this is platycardic.
Now the peakedness eventually tells about the concentration around the center part of
the data. If the peakedness is high around the center of the data dealing with that data
is much more easier than the peakedness is lower and the flat is it is much more flatter
distribution. Dealing with this type of distribution is much more challenging compared to dealing
with this distribution. This distribution will behave more decently and well obedient
way but this one will not behave in such a way. And here the quartiles that we define.
So here you can see that the distribution of a random variable the first 25% is here.
So the Q1 is the value such that the data less than that is 25%. Q2 which is eventually
the median 50% data is less than that 50% data is above that. Third quartile is the value
for which the 75% data less than that and 25% data above that. Then Q3 minus Q1 that is
known as the interquartile distance or interquartile range whatever we call that is also a measure
of the dispersion people often take. Median is the second quartile they are synonymous
that is the 50% of the data.
Now I think I should take a break so with the descriptive statistics we will we are concluding
here. And if you want to capture the measurement of skewness and cartosis these two will be
the formula for skewness and cartosis with depending on quartile this is the formula
for skewness and depending on the mean and other or the moments this is the measurement
of the skewness and this is the measurement of the cartosis. So this one numerically positive
means positive skew, numerically negative means negatively skewed. This value we compare
with 3, 3 is with this formula 3 will be the cartosis of standard normal distribution.
So if this is larger than 3 is positively carted if less than 3 for this number is negative
equity.
So with this note we are concluding this descriptive feature of the data. Now we will tell you
that how to overcome the shortage of this descriptive distribution through probabilistic
characterization of the data. Thank you.